-Performing "Bite Me,"
with special guest
Travis Barker,
here's Avril Lavigne!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Hey, you ♪
♪ Should've known better ♪
♪ Better to mess
with someone like me ♪
♪ Hey, you ♪
♪ Forever and ever, you're gonna
wish I was your wifey ♪
♪ Don't act so innocent ♪
♪ This was no accident ♪
♪ You planned this in the end,
and now it's over ♪
♪ Say what you want to say ♪
♪ You lied, and I got played ♪
♪ You threw it all away ♪
♪ And now it's over ♪
♪ Just face it,
we didn't make it ♪
♪ You bit off
more than you can chew ♪
♪ Can you taste it? ♪
♪ Hey, you ♪
♪ Should've known better ♪
♪ Better to mess
with someone like me ♪
♪ Hey, you ♪
♪ Forever and ever, you're gonna
wish I was your wifey ♪
♪ Should've held on,
should've treated me right ♪
♪ I gave you one chance,
you don't get it twice ♪
♪ Hey, you ♪
♪ And we'll be together never,
so, baby, you can bite me ♪
♪ Don't hold your breath ♪
♪ 'Cause you're still
choking on your words ♪
♪ Those things you said ♪
♪ Might be the last ones
that I heard ♪
♪ So come pick up your clothes
from the front yard ♪
♪ Sprinklers on ♪
♪ Burn the rest
in the backyard ♪
♪ Should've had the guts
just to say goodbye ♪
♪ Now you're gonna have regrets
for the rest of your life ♪
♪ Just face it ♪
♪ We didn't make it ♪
♪ You bit off
more than you can chew ♪
♪ Can you taste it? ♪
♪ Hey, you ♪
♪ Should've known better ♪
♪ Better to mess
with someone like me ♪
♪ Hey, you ♪
♪ Forever and ever, you're gonna
wish I was your wifey ♪
♪ Should've held on,
should've treated me right ♪
♪ I gave you one chance,
you don't get it twice ♪
♪ Hey, you ♪
♪ And we'll be together never,
so, baby, you can bite me ♪
♪ I bet you taste me
on the tip of your tongue ♪
♪ Tip of your tongue,
tip of your tongue ♪
♪ I fell fast when I know
I shoulda run ♪
♪ Know I shoulda run,
know I shoulda run ♪
♪ I bet you taste me
on the tip of your tongue ♪
♪ Tip of your tongue,
tip of your tongue ♪
♪ I fell fast
when I know I shoulda run ♪
♪ I know I shoulda run,
I know I shoulda run ♪
♪ Hey, you ♪
♪ Should've known better ♪
♪ Better to mess
with someone like me ♪
♪ Hey, you ♪
♪ Forever and ever, you're gonna
wish I was your wifey ♪
♪ Should've held on,
should've treated me right ♪
♪ I gave you one chance,
you don't get it twice ♪
♪ Hey, you ♪
♪ And we'll be together never,
so, baby, you can bite me ♪